dans le voisinage c'est l'effroi comment
le jeune homme qu'il croise tous les
jours at il pu tuer sa mère et surtout
pourquoi dans l'immeuble mère et fils
louer un appartement ici au premier
étage depuis deux ans nous sommes à
saint cyr sur loire à 500 mètres environ
de la place de la tranchée elle
travaille dans une maison de retraite
lui fréquente le collège becquerels
selon les voisins le duo est assez
complices voire fusionnelle l'adolescent
est avenant et discutent volontiers
d'après une locataire il est mature et
selon elle l'enfant était précoce il
aurait deux en avant ça l'école quand
bien même le garçon était saoul mesures
éducatives et a fait l'objet d'un suivi
psychologique
mercredi sans nouvelles de leur fille et
de leur petit fils les parents de la
victime préviennent les pompiers
finalement l'adolescent ouvre la porte à
ce moment précis les enquêteurs parlent
d'une scène d'une violence inouïe
la victime a reçu plusieurs dizaines de
coups de couteau placé en garde à vue de
mineurs a aujourd'hui été déféré puis
mis en examen pour assassinat
considérant donc que le crime a été
prémédité en effet selon des sources
proches du dossier le jeune homme aurait
spécifié sa volonté de supprimer sa mère
sur les réseaux sociaux
pour quelle raison l' enquête devra le
dire pour les mineurs âgés de 13 à 16
ans la peine de prison ne peut excéder
la moitié du maximum prévu pour les
majeurs pour les mêmes faits